That is it for stores. Also check out the lecture after this lecture where I also
prepared some additional things you can do with stores.
But the main thing about stores is that you can create writable and readable stores.
Readable stores are great for pieces of data that update automatically.
Writable stores will be the main stores you interact with because they allow you to both
subscribe to them
and trigger changes in the data
manually based on user events and so on.
And you also learned about custom stores,
which is a useful enhancement for writable stores,
where you can hide away some of the complexity
from your components
and put it into the store file instead
and have all your heavy lifting,
all your logic in the store file.
And in the components,
you can just call easy to use methods like remove item
and all the magic happens behind the scenes.
Stores are super useful features in Svelte because they allow you to outsource logic and most
importantly data management into dedicated files.
They make sure that you don't have infinitely long prop and custom event chains.
And they particularly make communicating between loosely related components like the product and the card component
here much easier.